all right Super Mario in 3d this is
going to be so awesome
or an absurdly easy Super Mario
platformer game Super Mario 3d Land are
so I don't know about you guys but I
love me a good Super Mario game these
games are always awesome usually are so
Super Mario 3d Land is pretty much basic
Super Mario game it's a Mario platformer
but it's on the 3ds so now we have 3d
like you know actual 3d graphics alright
so in a game like this the 3ds either
going to really help the game or it's
just gonna be some cheap 3d gimmick
luckily in Super Mario 3d Land the 3d
actually really works and it works well
it actually helps you play the game for
the most part the 3d in this game is
just solids more solid than most any
other movie I've ever seen Super Mario
3d Land really uses the 3d to its
advantage there are a few levels where
I'm like I don't know if I could have
played that if it was not in 3d so the
game actually uses the 3d as a necessary
part of the game not just oh it's pretty
because it's in 3d the gameplay plays
like classic Super Mario structure but
in 3d you know it's like New Super Mario
Brothers with some of the Mario 64
structure but it's you know it's in 3d
the levels are more linear than Super
Mario 64's not like this big open world
or anything like that it has more of a
path to it like a point a and point B
it's not like a locked-in path like
Crash Bandicoot I hope that makes sense
and I like the power-ups in this game
the tanuki suits back so that's awesome
you have a boomerang brother suit
remember in Super Mario Brothers 3 the
hammer Brothers suit was like the
coolest suit ever well now you have a
boomerang brother suit is a pretty sweet
suit and you have your fireball
power-ups you actually have this little
block with a propeller on the top where
you jump and you hold down jump again
it'll shoot up in the air it happens in
these overhead view levels it's really
cool in 3d it looks good and there's one
level in this game that's a total
throwback to Zelda you even unlock the
secret and does that Zelda chime as
great a couple things I didn't like the
levels were a bit small they just seemed
a bit small you do have those three
coins that new Super Mario Brothers has
me you got to find these three coins but
these three coins do not seem well
hidden at all there are a couple that
you have to search for yeah but all in
all they're pretty easy to find there's
one in particular I still can't find
what I have no idea where this thing is
the levels didn't seem hard at first you
get a lot of 1up so you have like over a
hundred lives at a point I have like 162
that's crazy and with 162 lives to spare
I was fighting Bowser and I was dying a
few times he was actually pretty hard
right there and what is
the game dude the game's like well
jeremy has 162 lives to spare he's
spared five all right let's give them an
absurd powerup it gives me this tanooki
suit feather that also makes me
indestructible that breaks the entire
game you only have it for that level but
still I shouldn't have it at all I hate
it when games pander to me if I suck at
a game just let me suck and let me die
alive I will then learn and adapt and
finally conquer it and I'll feel awesome
don't give me weird power-ups like that
that's stupid so at a point when I was
like this game is so absurdly easy it's
losing a couple points on my rating I'm
just saying then this happened and then
it got awesome and this might be seen as
a spoiler but I think it'll just be a
thing that'll keep people from returning
the game you might want to when you
think it's just too easy until now you
get all the special worlds unusually
special world is like eight levels
within one world Nets this special world
of worlds it's plural there are eight
worlds and a few levels within the world
it doubles the size of the game and some
of these levels are a bit harder some
are a lot harder at that point I got
excited I was like this is the Super
Mario 3d Land game that I wanted to play
from the beginning like the first half
of the game is a warm-up the second half
that's business
the coins are more hidden now these
things are really hard to find I like
that I like having a search for the
coins so the real problems I had with
the game we're only in the first half of
the game and after that I have nothing
really bad to say about the game I would
have it the second half of the game
didn't happen but since it did the game
is great if you have a 3ds buy this game
there's no reason not to get this game
that's the thing about these Nintendo
systems when you get a Nintendo system
like a Wii or a 3d as you maybe like or
as some of these games just pointless
and useless but the Nintendo brand games
in these Nintendo systems they are gold
Super Mario 3d Land is no exception it's
a little Super Mario Brothers 3 a little
bit of Super Mario 64 in just all-around
great game so what is your favorite
Super Mario Brothers game every one of
you has probably played it I'm just as
played at least one comment below let me
know and I know you guys really want me
to review Legend of Zelda Skyward Sword
and I will but there's a story behind
that I reserved the game at Best Buy and
then the game came out while I was
playing Skyrim so I was like alright
I'll just buy the game and I'm done with
Skyrim and I reserved the special
edition pack you know the one that comes
with the Wiimote the collector's edition
but they only hold the reserves for 5
days so they sold my copy and now no one
has it like nobody at all ever on the
face of the earth nobody has it so I can
either act like a soccer mom from a few
years ago in the holiday season who are
looking
the Wii Fit boards when no one had those
I can either buy the collector's edition
with the Wii mote on eBay for like 120
bucks or I can just buy the $50 one
after a week or so of searching I just
bought the $50 one so I just started it
and I will review it when I beat it the
situation really sucks though I wanted
my gold Wiimote and that's that and as
always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]